want to keep staring at the wall or do
you want to go to work I mean it's a
pretty interesting thought you and Tony
we're still gazing into each other's
eyes how do we look well we're not the
27 Yankees we got some headers they're
good they're not a team let's beat him
into shape
[Music]
Avengers hey everybody its Charlie this
is gonna be a video all about the
Captain Marvel deleted scene from
Avengers age of Ultron they were
thinking about including her way way
back during phase 2 obviously things
went down very differently but there's a
big story about why that happened and
where her scene would have gone because
originally she was a joss whedon idea
that then they just cut out at the last
minute and wound up not doing we're
doing a new iMacs giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave an avengers comment on the video
so the big deal with Avengers age of
Ultron is that they actually shot
footage intending to add Captain Marvel
and CG after the movie was done because
the movies takes so long to complete and
special effects you shoot a lot of
background plates for the special
effects artists that they just digitally
place things in characters anything that
you would want to add to a scene so this
is Kevin Feige he's quote about deleting
Captain Marvel out of Avengers age of
Ultron he says there were drafts that
maybe people somehow got their hands on
and read early included some characters
may be others but certainly one which is
why it's dangerous to read scripts early
on and talk about them early on making
you wonder who those other characters
they consider putting in Avengers age of
Ultron now this is just about Captain
Marvel but Kevin Feige also insinuates
that there were other early Avengers
characters they were thinking about
adding to the team for their phase 3
roster that they probably held off for
phase 4 that will meet pretty soon so
let that blow your mind which other big
a-list characters were they thinking
about adding to the team I'll talk about
who I think those characters are at the
end of the video this is primarily about
Captain Marvel though so he goes on to
say Captain Marvel was in a trap but to
me it would have done the character a
disservice to meet her fully formed in a
costume and part of the Avengers already
when 99% of the audience would go who
the hell is that it's just not the way
we've done it before
Thanos is the good version of the
audience members going who's that
because he's clearly a bad guy for comic
fans he represents a specific storyline
you can get the buzz started from fans
from non fans with that cameo as opposed
to a title character who deserves their
own story even Black Widow you don't
meet in the last two seconds of Iron Man
2 wearing her costume you evolved that
going forward then Kevin Feige goes on
to say the way would reveal Scarlet
Witch in costume at the end of the movie
those were Captain Marvel plate shots
for special effects to digitally at her
later in joss whedon said to me will
cast her later
question mark and I said yeah sure we'll
cast her later then you know what
happened later they decided to save her
for the Avengers infinity war
post-credit scene where they teased her
with the pager then you meet her in her
solo movie so when it came time to
actually use those special effects shots
and add them to the movie Joss Whedon's
like well if we're not gonna add Captain
Marvel we can use it for Scarlet Witch
and she'll just float down into frame
because Captain Marvel was gonna float
down into frame like that he says it
made sense for her character she's come
to their side talking about Scarlet
Witch and she deserves a cool intro
which will feed into another movie that
were start shooting in a few weeks that
movie was gonna be Captain America Civil
War Scarlet Witch is obviously a big
part of that movie the sokovia chords
and how they break apart so you do
wonder if they had actually put Captain
Marvel in that scene intro'd her
full-blown in costume she would have
been a member of the Avengers at the
beginning of Captain America Civil War
which team would she have fallen on what
has she been team Iron Man would she
have been team captain America then you
have the problem of a power imbalance so
in Captain America Civil War you have
Scarlet Witch versus vision to cosmic
level powered people so they sort of try
to balance the sides out a little bit
and it makes more sense emotionally that
they would be on opposing sides it
creates more drama and tension between
them but if you throw Captain Marvel
into the mix she's another
super-powerful character creating a huge
imbalance in one of the teams no matter
whose side she takes whether it be
Captain America or Iron Man in obviously
we have Civil War two that came out the
year the Captain America Civil War came
out there was more of a Captain Marvel
versus Iron Man over the case of a
special inhuman so that doesn't
necessarily mean that she would have
been teen cap just like war machine
she's a part of the military she
respects that structure so it'd be more
likely I think that she would choose the
side of the government even though she'd
be very sympathetic to what Captain
America is doing here's the other thing
too in their original plan to intro
Captain Marvel wait earlier during phase
three what would have probably happened
is is they would have had to do her solo
movies sometime before Captain America
Civil War so that you understand who she
is you actually care about that
character before they break the team
apart what would have probably happened
is that Avengers age of Ultron came out
spring 2015 you have a man in the wasp
which is the official sort of tag end of
is to beginning of phase three then in
2016 we actually only had two Marvel
movies and they've typically done three
movies per year for the last couple of
years so logically what they probably
would have tried to do is just get her
movie out around this time during 2016
so then a couple months later in the
spring you have Captain America Civil
War and it makes a lot more sense where
you see what her character is doing
you also can't forget the idea that they
still had to introduce Doctor Strange
which came out at the end of 2016 after
Captain America Civil War they saw the
intro black panther the only other movie
that they could have shuffled before
infinity war because that's like the
last opportunity you have the movie
before infinity war to establish all
your big characters before you tear them
all down because of Thanos and the
Infinity Gauntlet is that you may have
been able to do a third Thor film after
avengers endgame and make that more
about him establishing new Asgard you
can do a slightly different version of
the hella plot but largely you'd have to
change the nature of that film because
so much happened it was all about
destroying Asgard so that he was
unprepared before Atheros came an
alternate theory about the history of
the MCU if things had gone down
differently and they'd shuffled the
movies around you could have had Thanos
destroy Asgard with the Power Stone when
he came to find the tesseract he could
have just killed Odin then because the
whole arc adoring thor ragnarok was
about Thor learning to do things his own
way becoming a king in his own right
without having the crutch of his father
to lean on so in retrospect I'm totally
fine with them cutting Captain Marvel
out of the movie I feel like it was the
right decision and just not dealing with
her till you get to infinity war of
interest and game and Marvel phase 4
this is the short clip of them talking
about cycling the roster in a really big
way this is also important for what's
happening right now with infinity war in
Avengers endgame
my favorite part about Avengers age of
Ultron is what's brought into potential
at the end fun of the comics is the
shifting roster is the notion that the
Avengers begin as a certain roster of
people but over time some characters go
off into their own adventures new
characters come in so for us that was
always part and parcel of the concept of
the Avengers so it was always the idea
that we were going to mix up the
teammates I feel like this is really a
kind of a feeling of an ending of an era
in the beginning of another and I
welcome it I think it makes the audience
even that more invested in our
interpersonal relationships and the
future of these characters so that's
pretty cool
so you look at that and you remember
that they cycled the roster with each
new Avengers film except infinity war
and Avengers and game are meant to be
taken is sort of one really big movie
even though technically they're two
completely different stories they use
infinity war to clear a lot of the
roster a la the snap and dusting
everyone then heading into Avengers
endgame you have room for that extra
really big new character Captain Marvel
and when Kevin Feige teases the other
really big Avengers characters that they
thought about including an Avengers age
of Ultron but did not at the last minute
I think he's mostly talking about a
couple characters we saw during phase 3
and then some that we won't see till
phase 4 people like Ant Man Scott Lang
Hank Pym they were just gonna introduce
in the next movie makes sense why you
would just save them for the next movie
because that was coming up later in the
year there's really no reason to jam
them into the end of Avengers age of
Ultron
they probably considered an early
version of the wasp even though they
hadn't quite got to that point in the
movies yet they knew that they would do
ant-man and the wasp eventually but it
just took them a little while to get
there they probably considered black
panther early on because they knew that
he was going to be a really big
character during phase 3 but obviously
they just decided to save him for
Captain America Civil War there were
several different drafts of that too
especially one that did not include
spider-man if the Sony deal didn't go
through and of all the other characters
that could possibly fly and they could
use that plate for I don't think that
they'd be doing Adam warlock or any like
the really big cosmic characters like
Nova yet because I still think the
Captain Marvel was higher on their list
than some of those other characters that
we'll see during phase 4 like
obviously we're getting ready for Adam
warlock during guardians of the galaxy
vol 3 so he'll be a character eventually
Kevin Feige said that a Nova movie is
very high on their list so like a lot of
the bigger but secondary characters that
aren't necessarily critical to what's
going on right now will be much bigger
during phase 4 the only other really big
character that they cut out of Avengers
age of Ultron that they'd spent a lot of
time talking about was the grey version
of the Hulk and that actually came about
because of a couple errors during
post-production when Joss Whedon kept
pushing the special effects artist to
make him look crazier and crazier so
what happened is is that the color
timing of the scene changed him and he
started to look kind of gray so Joss
Whedon got the idea Oh gray hope from
the comics will just give that to you
and you can save him for later movie or
you can decide to do whatever you want
to with the character so in that case
they considered gray Hulk a completely
separate character than they would have
considered the regular version of the
Hulk because in this moment here when
he's been mind warped by Scarlet Witch
it's supposed to be the Hulk hulking out
which funny enough they actually did do
in the comics only his name was claw it
was basically Hulk spelled backwards and
it was during Avengers access when
everybody got their alignment changed
heading into Avengers endgame now we
obviously know we're probably not gonna
see grey Hulk
even though he's a chattier version of
the Hulk we're gonna see something more
akin to professor Hulk which is sort of
a balance between banner in the Hulk so
you have the mind of Banner but all the
strength and the power of the Hulk the
best of both worlds my Captain Marvel
review will post next week I'll do
Easter eggs and all the normal post
credit scene videos everything leave
your requests in the comments below
click here for all my Avengers and game
trailers and bonus videos and click here
for my non-spoilery Captain Marvel
review thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]